alors c'est antonio dans les années 60
qui commençait à avoir la pleine forme
ben il commencé à exister tout
simplement fait ils étaient ils étaient
beaucoup plus fringants évidemment
l'auteur tout au moins que fait que
maintenant mais c'est la vie je regrette
rien je regrette pas du tout cette
période encore qu'elle a été très belle
elle était belle parce qu'elle s'était
encore une époque d'insouciance
il y avait encore de la suite on sortait
d'un cauchemar on avait repris goût à la
vie et on croyait que la vie ça allait
être quelque chose de très bas tu mets
avant de replonger dans les années 70
dans le marasme dans la peur où nous
sommes maintenant d'ailleurs ça a été ça
a été vraiment comme une espèce de no
man's land quelque chose d'assez
miraculeux où tout était facile et il y
avait de l'espoir à ceux qui auront
l'impression que j'en sors tu connais un
petit peu aussi
oui mais et quand on est heureux on
s'ennuie jamais dit un autre mot pardon
mais ces salles le signe du bonheur
c'est qu'on s'emmerde
vous comprenez c'est les ennuis qui vous
tiennent compagnie alors donc que tout
baignait pas de raison de se formaliser
alors il y avait une espèce était un peu
longue 10 ans c'était un peu glissant
mais on avait le temps quand même de de
savourer justement les shows singulière
les artistes les sépare la nouvelle
cuisine et danser dans ces années là à
cette heure on avait le temps de penser
à des à des plaisirs du second degré
mais san antonio lui n'a pas vieilli
malgré tout il a gardé sa fraîcheur des
années 60 alors est ce qu'un auteur ne
pas tu peu jaloux de voir que son
personnage qu'il a créé et ne prend pas
une ride et puis ben lui il a perdu un
peu de cheveux non mais vous savez
manade dans jal est pris mes précautions
j'ai perdu mes cheveux avant des cas san
antonio c'était une bonne chose de faite
pas du tout je comprends pas que
certains auteurs soient soin jaloux dur
créatures moi quand tu joues avec cette
année par exemple san antonio est entré
dans le temps
rous je suis heureux je pissais c'est
mon enfant un père est heureux quand son
fils réussi j'ai fait un grand garçon
qui se défend bien bas je suis satisfait
quoi on se dit bon ben allal à la suite
est assurée